[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
three
all right
happy friday everyone it's almost the
weekend which means michael loftus heads
to his local goodwill and digs through a
fresh container of recently deloused
hobo clothes
[Laughter]
and cat tried to actually leave early
today to go to happy hour
you know
couldn't wait a few hours
and because i care about my health i'll
be working out
[Music]
[Music]
you know a disgusting person would say
he gives great head but i'm not that
kind of person
that was a fun little roller coaster of
reaction yes it was shock disgust and
then approval
which is where you want to land exactly
let's do that joke again do not edit
that out
so joe's approval ratings dropped to 38
according to the latest poll
that honeymoon ended faster than ilhan
omar's and her brothers
it's no surprise the presidency is
unraveling faster than a cardigan caught
in a power drill
just look at the key variables foreign
policy has been a disaster unless you're
the taliban and are doing donuts on a
soccer field in a u.s army jeep
as vice president joe went to funerals
as president he causes them
yes it's amazing this joker has been in
politics forever and the moment that
he's put in charge he wets the oval
office rug like a nervous puppy
i would not trust him with the keys to a
rascal scooter
i think that's one of our sponsors
inflation now hits american households
for an extra 175 bucks a month which is
exactly what hunter pays the masseuse
for a happy ending at the local super 8.
meanwhile gas prices are higher than cat
[Laughter]
just rhythmically yes it didn't work
rhythmically but he didn't have to
but that's another tax targeting the
working stiff you know the people who
have to drive to pay their bills instead
of selling arts and crafts for a half a
million
but of course the guy who says the buck
stops with me says it's not his fault
that the buck is worth a lot less than
it was a year ago
you've heard about the homicide numbers
even cartel members from tijuana won't
visit baltimore
in chicago more people are getting their
shots from a glock than a syringe
you got a dead domestic agenda the only
thing joe seems capable of passing his
gas from the gerber's pureed vegetables
he had for lunch
also there's more covered deaths under
joe in just 10 months with three
vaccines than all that of all of last
year good luck blaming it on trump but
of course they will yes remember that
constant body count that showed up every
day like stelter and krispy kreme
gleefully attributing every casualty to
trump even if the coveted victim was 600
pounds 90 years old and had a crowbar
through his head
they hoped the list would cost trump the
election and it did biden promises shut
the virus down instead the only thing he
is shutting down is the early bird
buffet
now when biden wins the body count
disappears much like cnn's fact checking
department which they put into cold
storage along with their ratings and
chris cuomo's career
so what do you say about all of this joe
look look look this is simple
i was saying this the other day on the
telephone the television
the radio the a-track player all right
it's so
simple
if it's good i did it [ __ ] stop's here
it's me all right
if
it's bad
it's the other guy that you know
you know who i'm talking about all right
so
just look if you got covid okay that's
him
if you got no covert that's me
i did that
okay
the border that's him
crime
that's him high taxes that's him okay
now what's me uh
let me think of some good things here
raindrops on roses and whispers
that's it both of those those are me
the quinnipiac's tim malloy summarizes
the brutal polling findings battered on
trust doubted on leadership and
challenge on overall competency
president biden continues a downward
slide to a number not seen since the
tough scrutiny of the trump
administration so did you notice
something there he says they haven't
seen findings like this since the tough
scrutiny of the trump administration so
what's the difference here there is no
tough scrutiny of the bide
administration at all the press looks
away like they've been shown erotic
photos of joy behar
this suggests
this suggests that if the scrutiny were
equal brains would explode either trump
would have been the greatest president
ever if they treated him fairly or joe
biden would be the worst president ever
if they treated him fairly it's
mind-boggling with biden it's parents at
school board meetings who are to blame
right or the unvaccinated or fox news
joe will be blaming the ghost of ronald
reagan whom he talks to every night at
the white house
meanwhile there are no comparisons
between joe and trump on any variable
economy foreign policy coveted crime the
border
and why because if you did that you
would see that trump would destroy biden
which returns us to two key points first
the media didn't care that president
trump improved the country why would
they most of them hate this place anyway
but he had to go his late night tweets
gave all of them early morning anxiety
and even with all his cash he still
wasn't one of them he was one of us
also he was a republican so he starts
off as hitler
we're on like three hitlers now one more
hitler and we have a box set
[Laughter]
[Applause]
clapping for hitler
so they gladly handed the country's keys
to some daughtering old mess who goes to
bed at 4pm but doesn't send mean tweets
but this happens almost every time a
democrat is in the white house it's like
we keep punching ourselves in the face
to see if it really hurts as much as we
thought it did four or eight years ago
it does
and what happened to that unity pledge
joe's about as unifying as farting in an
elevator
just ask cat
so to protect the media's precious
mental health we screwed our country
over so what happens when you realize
that reassessing trump only makes biden
look even worse if biden is worse than
what the media called an existential
threat then what do you call biden a
super duper accident existential threat
and if the media can't compare biden to
trump's achievements then what do you do
you talk about january 6th and white
supremacists
suddenly concerned parents become
domestic terrorists and surprise amazing
the facebook whistleblower who just
miraculously showed up on 60 minutes
will now be testifying at the next
january 6th hearing so once again the
media and the democrats are in cahoots
which is necessary with these polling
numbers if biden got any more underwater
he'd be aquaman
let's welcome tonight's carrier
they said it couldn't be done
but we booked miss florida citrus 2002
former state department spokeswoman
morgan ortega
her name's lithuanian for helping greg
reach stuff from the top shelf fox news
headlines 24 7 host carly shimkus
i would hate to see what this guy wears
on laundry day
the loftus party.com founder michael
loftus
and when she is uh not being a diva oh
i'm sorry she's not being a diva when
she yells do you know who i am she
honestly can't remember
fox news contributor cat tim
so morgan
i almost wore the same thing oh
yes yes yes but i talked to fox we can't
wear the same thing on on this show
here's here's the amazing thing this guy
has been in politics for half a century
right and he sucks
so that tells me that no matter how long
you're in politics it doesn't improve
with experience it actually protects
incompetence whereas you have somebody
like trump who had no experience
actually do a better job so what does
that say about politics in general uh it
sucks probably
but he has been around forever and you
know it's funny because he was sort of
the butt of the jokes of the democrat
democratic party for a long time right
you remember in the 2008 debates when he
was on stage and they were like can you
stop talking joe yeah and he was sort of
the joke who just stayed around long
enough and then actually got elected but
you know his poll numbers are terrible
today also the jobs numbers i think that
women lost 28 000 jobs we didn't gain
any jobs we actually lost 28 000 and
it's not just because i think you know
biden you know bless his heart has seen
better years i think the policies are
really bad like it's really funny to
read the business headlines today they
were like women are having to stay at
home because the daycare and schools are
close no
right
who who else is going to i mean you know
the husband's help but like of course
it's disproportionately affecting women
these bad policies yeah you know michael
uh her point about uh
joe uh it's kind of like your strategy
at a bar you know stay around long
enough and you might get lucky
yeah right around 2 a.m everybody's
hammered you're like oh joe's feeling
good america
he was a good screw-in last last call
joe he was last call joe yes and it's
these poll numbers like who's shocked by
these a guy who's been absolutely
horrible for 48 years
oh now he's horrible at this job too wow
let's put him behind the wheel of a
ferrari he wrecked it who knew yeah his
numbers are dropping fast they are
dropping how fast they're dropping
faster than nancy pelosi's granny
panties at a chardonnay taste an evening
[Applause]
how fast
thanks to the hunter biden dropping to
his knees at a parmesan carpet cleaning
contest
one more how fast
faster than gavin newsom's mask at the
french laundry buffet
all right
that is a skill oh it's fun but our
national it's funny like these numbers
are not a shock to like half the country
yeah half the country is just we just
started we're eight months into the
longest game of we told you so yeah ever
in the history of mankind carly you look
very sparkly today thank you
what do you make of this do you what i
my my prediction is the worst that joe
gets
the more intensely the media will focus
on domestic terror
absolutely and you know um it is
interesting because as you know there
are tvs all over the floors here at fox
news that show what's on our air uh fbn
cnn msnbc and as we're covering the news
of the day it is really fascinating to
see how all the other networks are still
really stuck on january 6th and it's
really because that's all they have um
and president biden if you think about
why he was elected into office it's
really to be a placeholder president
nobody voted for him because he inspired
the masses the people who did just
didn't want trump and i think that
there's a lot of buyer's remorse there
because like you said the poll numbers
on the economy afghanistan foreign
policy
crime those are obvious because we're
obviously doing bad in those areas but
the poll numbers on biden's personality
are really interesting
is he honest that dropped 20 points over
the last eight months does he care about
the average american that dropped 11.
and his personality was his bread and
butter the fact that he was going to be
a moderate also both things that's not
the reality right now i don't think he
eats bread and butter i think it's
usually metaphor yeah it's got to be
something smooth
softer easily digestible softer
so i'm speaking from an experienced cat
yeah what do you make of this uh these
polling numbers for joe will the
administration change course that's a
special report kind of question i've
never been on that show believe it or
not
uh
let's see how i do
no i don't think they'll change course
because first of all i don't think he's
the one thinking about it at all i think
that whatever people tell him to do he
says okay right he reads off the
prompter and that's all he does but they
still keep going back to the trump thing
because that's where they set the bar
they said if you don't vote for this guy
and trump is the president all of
civilization will collapse and everyone
will die
and as dumb as that is
people believed it yes people were
really concerned that that would happen
so i think that there's still going to
be people hanging on saying well at
least civilization's not collapsed but
at this point we're getting kind of
close yeah
no it was apocalypse every day yeah
and what is it now it's like it's like
it's doom but everybody's just
pretending like it's not our fault
though
everything that goes wrong instead of
focusing on fixing it they focus on the
pr strategy of why it's not their fault
exactly hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else